okay
your schedule on December 25th every
year
what are we doing I'm saying Nick baby
are we bringing everyone to the same
crib I think I always I was saying this
I think that only benefits me you know
what I mean because then everybody has
to come to me I think that's pretty
selfish 12 kids you got 24 hours in a
day on Christmas yeah just the half
Latino ones get Christmas Eve because
that's their day well you know what
they're to your point you're joking
that's the truth because Abby and her
kids they celebrate Christmas on on the
24th you see you know how this works
like some tamales yeah exactly no uh to
be honest though it is really about I
mean I just it just happened even again
with Easter it's like you know you don't
you don't necessarily have to operate
based off of the the social construct
that everybody else is subscribed to so
we make sure that we we celebrate
Christmas however long we want to
celebrate Christmas so it could be the
27th I mean not that late but I mean
like it's a it's enough it could be the
22nd yeah you know they always wonder
how Santa Claus can deliver all those
presents and still get home to Mrs Claus
by the morning so it's a we move around
and I'm I'm festive like that as much as
holidays the pagan holidays don't matter
to me I love what it does for children
so I'm always dressing up and Chris it
ain't Christmas day it's Christmas week
you know I'm in my house it's a week
yeah it has to be a week yeah like we
throwing Easter egg hunts all week long
when it's Easter time I mean all the
moms and kids live in Cali besides
Mariah she lives in Cali too okay yeah I
mean she's obviously you know she got
property yeah
but that's usually it is you know we we
got we got houses on the east coast and
the West Coast so we everybody's the
newer children are all in Cali uh
currently yeah yeah I told you I got
Calabasas on a lot you just yeah
it's Canon bastards everyone's over
there everybody's over there that
Ralph's got it yeah mom's got to be
running into each other Ralph's and [__]
we lit we turn we tear the commons up
are are you your kids moms friends at
all uh what I never like to generalize
because or they or are they at least
cordial friends like they don't like the
ones who it's like they I I'll leave
that up to them in the narratives in
which they share every no like everybody
is
like nurturing and loving and respectful
enough that they they understand what's
going on so nobody got any problems or
any negativity like we fly on a higher
frequency than that so like but I ain't
you know don't expect everybody to be
hanging out together but it's like
listen I'm just trying to figure because
I've seen a lot of these Cults or cold
Netflix documentaries recently the Canon
cult is the Canon cult a thing you must
wear a turban in Vietnam you must have
at least one base to operate against the
circadian clock
um nah man I think it's just I mean
obviously I'm probably just more open
and honest about myself you are very
very transparent about it I think look
at look at you know everybody from the
Bob Marley's to the Muhammad Ali's to
the you know Quincy Joneses of the world
these all of these great men have are
fathers of many and right but I do think
what you did was you did it all at once
once hey man the clock is ticking it
felt like it was so crazy because like
we do a national syndicated radio show
every day and
I couldn't talk about you on the show
because our biggest affiliate was a real
923 yeah Power 106. and I did they
literally tell you don't talk about it I
just you know just shout out to Doc I
ain't [__] with doctors of course he
is but our kids was playing together
when we was competition so
um it would be crazy because me and
James would be like [__] Nick's having a
[__] we can't talk about it felt like
every six weeks there was just a new I
think it's it's it's you know because
all the kids are going to be pretty soon
so this is going to be an interesting
upbringing I mean I'm pretty sure there
will be some challenge but I think
there'll be some beautiful things like
graduation put them all in the same
school I'm hoping I mean in the same
area it all depends you know what I mean
but you know even some of my kids right
now are homeschooled so it's like we'll
we'll figure all of that stuff what will
school be in 10 years if you want to be
honest with it you know based off of the
way the world is going so I I think you
know a lot of my kids right now are
active in extracurricular activities and
sports and stuff so that probably might
become challenging to where you know
they're definitely trying to make a
certain similar games on certain days
right right now you know baseball
basketball on track overlap you know
what I mean so even sometimes they can't
even make it to their own games so it's
like it's always going to be something
you've only been married once so what's
tomorrow yeah yeah yeah and only will be
married once it's only going to happen
so when all this starts first happening
right yeah does Mariah call you be like
what the [__] are you doing bro oh not
really we have that type of like type of
conversation but she's a little bit more
understanding she's got to be like I'll
see you out there Making Waves like she
kind of comes from it more from that
perspective but that there was no I
think only sometimes maybe when things
in the media get misconstrued or people
make up stuff like you got to clear it
up yeah we talk every day so I'm like yo
like it was some wow [__] of like saying
that we were having like a custody
battle or something I saw that yeah and
it's like I was like we just was at
dinner yesterday you ain't tell me you
know but it's like once we kind of do
away without all the rumors because
people do like to start rumors and
operate in that low frequency but we are
we all be on the same phase do you still
have the tattoo would you cover it up I
added to it shall we say cat
it's my whole that was my only tattoo at
one time now I remember I remember yeah
I was like this this guy's outside yeah
yeah yeah he got the homeless Mariah
Carey damn right I can't buy or nothing
that she can't buy it Ryan Carey was my
as a small child she was like my first
crush yeah so when I saw I was like
shout out to Nick man it was Brian JLo
yeah and actually my boy ended up being
with JLo Casper Smart see look at this
these young tycoons out here in these
streets getting it together man